um the next category is
uh they actually talked about anime
awards so uh
so if you're a new viewer of trash chase
you may not know this but uh we want or
an anime podcast no we weren't
no we we said we were literal episode
two we didn't talk about anime we once
said that we were an anime podcast and i
don't know the exact moment when we're
just like no we started with the
intention of being an anime podcast and
then by halfway no no we didn't we
started with the intention of
tricking people into thinking we're
going to have my podcast
but yeah guys we're definitely an anime
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then uh
definitely it took like way less time
than i thought it would to be like no we
know that one episode
one episode literally episode two we
don't talk about anime yeah so
we did also talk about anime uh we are a
podcast
yeah yeah i'd say i like to think you
like to think every now and then we
spoke about it yeah
we're going to represent our original ip
yeah let's see all right so first of all
connor watch all of mushoku tensei which
i think was a surprise to a lot of
people i'm sorry i'm so proud i'm so
proud i'm still proud
to be fair uh joey thought jesus christ
was okay here we go again here we go
again uh the boys talk about berserk for
30 minutes oh this was when uh mira
sensei passed away this is a shame
because at this point i hadn't read
berserk yeah
and during the manger episode we
actually talked about it that also i
think could have been referring to the
manga episode oh could you i hope i
don't believe it was initially just
about the manga yeah
um
was this the one where we had that
unfortunate timing yeah yeah
yeah so like so like as much as i like
berserk and i'm glad we talked about
berserking for 30 minutes i think this
is actually referring to the manga
episode okay okay yeah yeah okay we
didn't have this point as well yeah yeah
yeah we've talked about we've touched on
bizarre a couple of times yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's amazing okay
uh conor and gone try to get joey to
watch arcane okay is not an anime
it's an animal it's a cartoon come on
let's be real guys
right now
and then the boys talk about not
watching anime how's that wait hold on a
second how is that in this award
okay can i can i see this clip yeah yeah
you guys voted for these nominations by
the way it really says a lot about anime
when all it takes is for me to read a
synopsis
and i could probably tell you with 90
accuracy what the first three episodes
of that anime is going to be about in in
a detailed way yeah we were we were like
such an anime podcast that we had like a
[ __ ] 20 minute conversation about not
talking about anime anymore
i remember this conversation i still
stand by at that point yeah yeah
definitely ah well [ __ ] i mean
i purely just from the fact that it was
nominated in the other ones i would
probably have to say
me thinking jesus christ was like i want
that one to win yeah i just wanted to
get somewhere
i want it so nobody forgets that joey
thinks jujitsu is okay i will keep
reminding everyone every day
all right let's find out i guess all
right uh that's not me no it is
absolutely you picked it up all right
all right right right
i'm on i'm gonna timeline he's got
dimension
champagne what timeline am i in
uh and the winner is
john and connor trying to get joey to
watch oh wow okay
that's surprising as you should have
watched it yeah yeah i definitely will
watch it how many episodes ago was that
like thirty
i think i said episode 77 so that's 30
episodes
it's amazing when season two comes out
it'll happen all over again what uh what
percentage did it win by
that one won
four point nine percent of the vote oh
that's really close
in second place with twenty three point
five percent of the vote connor watched
all of musa yeah i would have voted for
that one i thought that would yeah
because that was like surprising i
remember because
we talk about anime what what like my
recommendation about an isa guy what
never happens yeah never happens oh wow
all right yeah i like the fact that it's
the they actually talked about anime
awards and uh the arcade
arcade
everyone everyone's in the wrong time
yeah everyone everyone's not figuring it
out the best tangent ward so all of
trash day it's essentially the entirety
of this podcast all right creating a
conversation was an olympic sport we'd
beat the world championship we'd
definitely be the world champions let's
see the nominations what are the
nominations all right i'm gonna do it so
three things you would take to a
deserted island
okay it's not a tangent i get i guess
it's kind of yeah because the question
was suddenly like thrown out of nowhere
right yeah i threw it out there just
randomly okay and then talking about
dreams talking about are we watching the
clips for these you can i would i would
like to because i would like to see our
reaction to some of the tangents if
there are real i can't understand yeah
play the first one first can i take a
boat
like a really nice yacht
i'll just take my six million dollar
mansion no one said the scale of items i
i can bring why can't i bring a boat
well then i'll bring a jet and get the
[ __ ] out
okay so like i i think some of these
might have like more like immediate
tangents we'll see we'll see oh because
some of these inspired entire episodes
right yeah you're talking about dreams
one i think it was just one
i don't know led to that oh i think it
was about you talking about sydney
having fever dreams yeah okay then we
went and then the rest of the episode
was just about dreams
that that was a tangent that defined an
episode you know i didn't even remember
what the [ __ ] we were talking about that
was like actually one of my favorite
episodes to record because i was just it
was just such a weird conversation that
i've never had before and then conor
thinks deer are the scariest valid valid
valid oh i love this one turkish taxi
drivers of the mafia can you play this
clip actually yeah i want to play this
clip army of taxi drivers ready to beat
you up
like literally my taxi driver bro cause
they're like they're like the mafia of
turkey
dude in turkey they say don't [ __ ] with
bus drivers and taxi drivers [ __ ] with
one of them you you you call up the
entire neighborhood
why do like
that that single handling made me not
want to go to tokyo yeah right
that sounds terrible what are you gonna
do piss off taxi drivers yeah i don't
know like i don't know where they're
like fuse is right that was such a weird
tangent
yeah and then the boys
yeah and then jan talks about the
touches
i want to watch this one i want to watch
this one because i remember like having
visual shocked this one yeah i think so
basically you know itachi
sacrificed his whole life being for the
greater good that he believed in
a shoe he had to fill in at a age that
you know even he had no understanding or
conscious about okay stop laughing [ __ ]
i think connor sums it up there because
i remember he was having what was he
talking about before though i don't know
it was something he was talking about
like how like
like a host he respected or something
yeah and then and then he was suddenly
like dude it's like
what i remember getting like
mental whiplash like here in this
conversation and
where the [ __ ] did that come from and
then uh ordering a staff cross pizza
during recording oh yeah i think that is
like if you're technically speaking the
like strongest tangent that is literally
derailed the episode
yeah yeah yeah to discuss this we
completely paused the episode for a
moment so we could have hot dogs in
crust yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i think
it's delicious that's the only that's a
few times where we've actually like just
ate on a yeah i mean like i guess like
technically speaking yes you're right
that is like the biggest tangent but
we're not talking about yeah we're not
talking about biggest tangent we're
talking about best tangent and i think
itachi sacrifice i think is
like by far my favorite tangent i don't
think it'll win
for me it's either that or the eating
the extinct tortoises i think people
really enjoyed the tortoise bit yeah i
think that was a good bit that was a
good bit it's true
all right like these are just like
random conversations i guess i just like
the itachi sacrifice just came out
nowhere and i hope that wins let's find
out all right the best tangent as voted
by you the viewers was
i was right again boys i'm [ __ ] uh
what is this
boys want to eat extinct tortoises oh
wow oh i keep getting it right i know
the fans i know you why did you vote me
as biggest clown no [ __ ] you all except
when he uh has
selective memories
even though i don't think the views
reflected it i think this is one of our
like strongest episodes yeah yeah i
thought we were just on point yeah yeah
everyone had jokes yeah every everyone
just came out swinging i think we had
the good discussion about the deserted
island oh yeah yeah and the zombie
apocalypse yeah yeah
we were just like on point that was like
one of my favorite episodes i don't
think it got nominated for best episode
though
that one came in first with thirty one
point five percent of that okay
oh yeah in second place were the turkish
mafias i mean the taxi drivers with 5
16.
okay yeah i think i was going to say
that i think the jan episode in general
was just like a really really good i
mean we were just like vibing with jan
and jan spews like the most random [ __ ]
all the time anyway that's just that's
just jan off camera yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly definitely all right um you'd be
happy to know that third place was your
stuffed crust pizza with fourteen point
two really okay that's surprising
actually yeah yeah yeah didn't think
about that all right